bene a tutti ragazzi è venuto nessuno
video sono fa vj
oggi è sabato e quindi siamo in un nuovo
blog così da tutti i sabati sin da
quando è nato gesù di cui ai ragazzi
cosa in ambulanza prima di cominciare
l'ambulanza grazie grazie
meno morti adesso grazie e cominci a
ragazzi con solito ripartire con la fa
parte a settimana che questa settimana è
stata vinta da un sarto che ha fatto
questo disegno della madonna che già ha
fatto un bisogno della madonna questo è
più della madonna ancora probabilmente
vado è madonna che fa questi disegni
grazie comunque fantastico volevo dirvi
ancora che alla siccome ti voglio in
questa settimana ho dovuto passare due
giorni interi a registrare video per
coprire tutta la settimana siccome io
per fare un video ci metto tipo sei ore
o fateli circa cinque o sei video sono
stato presente fisso al corso da tre
giorni fisso così al computer con gli
occhi così per fare video appunto perché
sennò poi rimanete tipo farvi perché era
un infarto video ok
li ho fatti sto facendo e siccome sto
facendo sarobba mi sono fatto portare la
pizza a casa quindi questo blog lo farò
con la pizza perché sono lontano tempo
marco di mangiare a stento vado a cagare
dai ragazzi siccome in casa non c'ho la
cucina io ma ho quella fottutissima
libreria che non serva un cazzo non
posso avere le posate o cose tipo il
lavello lo vede genere quindi prendo le
posate di plastica adesso devo mangiare
la pizza con questa cosa che non è tutto
fuorché un coltello sembra più un
giocattolo e detto queste ragazzine che
possono ne sto facendo cose oscene sta
tagliando la pizza non perché sembra
brutto così sembra molto brutto
[Musica]
ecco questo ragazzi quindi direi di
passare alle sono contentissimo che vi
sia piaciuto al blog di los angeles mi
piace un casino quell'asta tipologia di
video quindi non vedo l'ora di rifarlo a
giugno poi tornerò di nuovo los angeles
dal 13 al 20 la farò un altro video
della madonna demon così però per ora un
attimino sto col culo a casa perché
devono mangiare la pizza come non so
prendo più parti ragazzi perché mi sono
trasferito a milano e non c'è più il
punto posta sto facendo aprire un altro
fermo posta a milano quindi madonna la
vita ho chiesto io perché sono un se
moderno manca morì a casa ragazzi
passiamo alla agli eventi bellissimi di
questa settimana che sono stati
veramente fantastici diciamo che è
successo quando sono tornato da los
angeles siccome non pulivo caso a un
pochettino perché ero a los angeles
hanno tornata a casa ha trovato una cosa
meravigliosa c'era un ragno grosso così
sul cazzo di mou era qua era esattamente
qui in questo punto io non stavo per
fare un game perché questa è la mia
postazione socia la pizza ma qua io
faccio il gameplay mi sono seduto ho
fatto così ha detto bene io non faccio
più un cazzo cambio caso siccome dovevo
fare video perché era già tardi non
riuscivo più a farlo se no ho tentato di
uccidere il ragno e ho filmato la cosa a
voi commenti capitana [ __ ] mi fa schifo
devo documentare questa cosa perché
nella v no no ma mi ha allora ragazzi e
grosso
cristian è grosso come un iphone 6 no no
no
no no no no no è cristo sto facendo il
video di questa cosa invece che che deve
fare qualcosa perché non so che cazzo
fare siccome vivo da solo che non sono
sposato non avreste mai detto con in
panico io per questa cosa sono
esageratamente in panico ho chiamato mio
zio non è lontano non è che voglio
chiamare una persona per uccidere un
cristo di ragno michael e spider man
sul muro porca [ __ ] c'è veramente
grosso la cosa bella di quando succede
questa cosa che devo guardarlo perché se
lui si muove non lo trovo più mi incazzo
il problema è che non riesco non riesco
a guardarlo quindi lo faccio così non
c'e la stoffa c'è una sofferenza c'è
qualcosa tipo sco venoso c'è da sé ma
perché ho deciso di vivere da solo non
mi fa schifo toccare qualsiasi cosa che
ci ho paura che escano i ragni non so
perché questo stop festa questa non so
se basta ragazzi non ne ho la più
pallida idea cpc provo per che più di
così non posso farlo
e morto è morto non lo so ragazzi non
sanno importa non lo so se il morto non
c'è più
non c'è più è sparito ragazzi è sparito
ragno porta [ __ ]
no no no no no no
diciamo ragazzi che questa cosa non è
una fine ancora perché in realtà non ho
mai trovato quell'affare che situazione
di merda tutti ragazzi detto questo noi
che possiamo passare fare risponde
sperando di non essere mangiati vivi da
animali e cose la prima domanda arriva
da paola che mi chiede favi per ora favi
per ora ga favi per ora gr sempre video
di circa 10 minuti basta favi fai un
video con blog gameplay fa vi risponde
cazzeggio time di almeno 45 minuti se
non più spolli chat e alla per fare
dieci minuti di video impiego più o meno
sei ore tra registrare montare caricare
video per farne uno di 45 minuti ce ne
metto 27 più o meno quindi non avrei
abbastanza tempo durante l'arco della
giornata e devo togliere il fatto che
non vado a mangiare che non vado a
pisciare che non vado a dormire che non
vado a respirare me lo fai tu un video
di 45 minuti così queste perché non
faccio video che lui è di 10 minuti
perché se no non avrei una vita sociale
che già non ho punto la pasta sul cdt
sofia perché non fai perchè non fai più
cazzeggio time non lo faccio spesso con
il fa vi risponde perché il cazzeggio
time è diverso cioè nel senso non è
settimanale e quando cazzo capita perché
si chiama appunto cazzeggio time quindi
quando cazzeggio lo faccio potrebbe
passare anche un mese senza cazzeggio
tempo poi potrei farne anche due di
seguito non l'idea dipende c'è una cosa
casuale quindi non ha una tempo e quando
lo faccio lo faccio è angelo bava fare
il prima eri bravo ma adesso la fama ti
ha dato alla testa
tu non sei il vero fa vj 1000 1 f
minuscola 6131 maiuscola 0 0 0 1 f
minuscola 6 14
ci sia da ciro buonasera si salve vorrei
ordinare una pizza che c'è ancora fama
ordinare una pizza una pizza che ci
affama ciò fa mai che ho mangiato guardi
prima ma c'è ancora fanno tanta proprio
capito mi scusi no a ciò la pizza a una
bene ascolti della pizza
allora io ho mangiato una pizza perciò
fama e ne voglio ancora un pochettino si
può potrebbe e ho capito com'è come era
stata la cosa più epica che abbia mai
fatto nella storia non lo farò mai più
perché mi sono vergognato come lo schifo
lo so se sei veramente chi cazzo sono le
persone che veramente si montano la
testa per quello che fanno
credimi che non è così perché se non
fare i video tipo nicchia ma un figura
madonna caf guardo non proprio la
persona è opposta di carattere se pensi
così perché non mi conosci per niente e
mi dispiace però l'idea è tua
pensavano come lucia farisei fai un
video mentre fai il pazzo allora lucia
io non so da quanto più o meno tu mi
segua più o meno guardare anche un solo
video a caso c'è bisogno che io faccia
il passo sono pazzo proprio quindi stai
tranquilla guardati un po di roba te ne
accorgerai ma molto facilmente proprio
d'accordo ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio spero che video vi sia
piaciuto niente volevo chiedervi prima
di andare a finire la pizza non ho
finita ma devo mangiato in ordinata
un'altra secondo voi quella merda chiara
peccato sul muro prima è uscita
direttamente da dark soul fatemi sapere
perché ho bisogno di trovare un'arma per
ucciderla lazer gun oppure una striscia
da guerra quindi ragazzi infatti di
sapere se avete questa informazione
perché io devo scappare dal terrazzo e
quindi ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto come asserito seguito è
piaciuto a sotto momento vi piace anche
a pagina di facebook e come non divido
tra tante sezioni sono sempre stati
scritti diavolo prossimo vino della
ragazze